Thanks very much for the talk, its a fantastic subject.
If everything were symmetrical or is symmetrical
You've got the particles and the forces  and you're saying they're part of the same thing.
You would expect, or at least I think you would expect, that everything will come to equilibrium pretty soon.
As it seems, we're 14 billion years down the line,
We've still got interactions and it doesn't seem to settle down.
Is there a chance that there are more things?
Because I know that it's a human thing to want beauty.
It's a very objective, sorry a subjective, wish.
It might be beautiful but it won't seem that way.
You started out with the question of does the world embody beautiful ideas
and you told us of the four yogas or the four forces.
It popped into my mind the question -
Could there be a fifth yoga? The yoga of everything?
that says something like - the world tells ideas what to say and ideas tell the world how to be.
I read an article in the New York Times recently...
Empirical evidence in modern physics is becoming less relevant.
The example he gave was supersymmetry
where the LHC doesn't actually find the supersymmetry particle.
It is possible now because of the complexities of physics to say that there are heavier particles
So I guess the question is - is there a bias towards beauty?
And at what stage does one decide to abandon the theory?
Because it's too hard to actually prove...
Is symmetry co-ordinate free?
You seem to start off with Galilean relativity which has Euclidean dimensions.
And then there's non-Eucledian geometry, space time...
Can it operate in both systems or is it limited upon that perception of what coordinate geometry you operate?
So in a sense it's conceptually dependant on geometry.
We couldn't understand it at all without a Euclidean or non-Euclidean perception.
I have two questions. First of all - is beauty intrinsic?
You said earlier that at some point in the far far future there will be symmetry throughout the universe.
Does that not contradict the law of thermodynamics that entropy will increase in time?
You talk about how force and substance can be co-moderated by each other.
Does that have anything to do with particle duality?
When you come across a problem that you can't find a solution to
what are your methods for moving forward with that problem?